on va parler de tf1 et des castings
médiocre de tf1 alors de tf1 casting
médiocre en général mais sur tf1 en
particulier puisque il ya eu un gag avec
matt singer j'allais lancer une grande
star internationale
on avait imaginé évidemment beyoncé on
avait mêlée n'est que du bon pamela
anderson il avait eu pour le pour
l'adorer dépouille soit est une vraie
star internationale et finalement on a
eu une star internationale mais en fait
international chez elle oui bah si vous
êtes dire on va regarder en images et
vous dirai après si vous la connaissez
voilà tu veux y aller c'est gérard y
aller je vais partir soyons fausses sur
un canot minogue
avec shakira chacun tu vas quand j'ai vu
la ballerine j'ai pensé aussi à natalie
portman ce qu'elle avait fait ce film
sublime tout à fait ma lady gaga lady
gaga hockey
eva longoria le jeu pas sûr du tout
obama aussi
[Musique]
il tient époux kyocera
gaza des poubelles
[Applaudissements]
et
ouais
[Musique]
alors là j'étais jeune et si si si
désolé alors c'est alors c'est une
grande comédienne qui a fait un carton
sur les fixes savoir casa del papel
voilà c'était le pape lcl pape lg lui
parce que c'est moi si on n'a pas des
fictions connais pas cette dame d'où il
les tient à présent à l'étranger à dire
vous connaissez alors ça m'a rassuré
puisque tout de suite j'ai twitté en
disant mais qu'est ce que je suis
vieille et je la connais pas mais oui à
tout le monde
réponse en dix ans mais ne t'inquiète
pas nous non plus on sait vaguement que
ces cas là donc je me suis sentie moins
seule
un masque autrement ce sens inverse
franchement et on se sent un peu de moi
excusez moi peut pas mettre des stars un
garde à l'ol est hyper connue elle
entend bien d'autres choses elle est
super connu c'est une star nationale
casa del papel c1 c'est ainsi un carton
dans le monde entier
franchement s'il est bien une star la
définition c'est que toutes les
générations la côte pour se faire une
idée sur le sujet est ce que les noms
des missions avec star star de
ramasseurs de derrière on n'a pas pu
arrêter le mot star et menacer les
briques mais célébrités je suis d'abord
ou mieux veux te venez tout net il ya
une recette qu'utilise tf1 depuis de
nombreuses années pour créer l'événement
faire appel à des stars dans ses
programmes par mais cette recette
magique à une limite
encore faut-il que les stars accepte de
participer et qu'on se le dise c'est
loin d'être le cas il ya quelques années
de grandes personnalités accepté de se
prêter au jeu des émissions de
divertissement
la première chaîne semble avoir de plus
en plus
et à fédérer et convaincre les vraies
stars de s'afficher sur la chaîne
c'est choquant ainsi le casting de
l'émission comme masque singer dont le
principe repose sur la célébrité de ses
participants affiche un casting assez
pauvre qu'il s'agisse de smaïn lio marie
josé pérec ou frédérique bel cette année
on est loin du festival de cannes
idem côté avec les stars dans lequel tf1
d'où sortent chaque année des célébrités
maison dont personne n'a jamais entendu
parler ce qui compte c'est vraiment le
charisme et que dire de stars à nu dont
le casting composé de philippe candeloro
bruno guillon ou encore alexandre de
waze est assez similaire à celui de
vettel
mon problème c'est que je ne sais pas
dire non au vote alors tf1 devrait-elle
arrêter des émissions autour des stars
alors de temps en temps il ya un ou deux
miracles ils vont vraiment une part
importante mais globalement c'est vrai
que c'est extrêmement pauvre et que le
mot star en tout cas pour moi je vous le
dis franchement le mot star depuis très
longtemps et totalement galvaudé c'est
lui qu'on sort bien deux stars de la
télé-réalité excusez moi c'est tout sauf
des stars aussi ont des inconnus
célèbres discours s'est pas dit s'il
n'avait pas un esprit ouvert vous êtes
fermés sont bonnes le mot star à
dépendre de notre vision pour moi ma
star à moi ça sera pas la même que la
vôtre tout simplement les stars de
télé-réalité comme vous dites ce sont
des stars pour certaines personnes pour
10 points devait dire si l'on voulait
moi je le sais je le vois au quotidien
il faut arrêter de stigmatiser le
concept forcément je me ferai jamais
j'ai pour d'autres une autre personne
est une star c'est comme ça x men on a
gagné ce qu'il y avait un million de
personnes qui regardent une émission de
5 1 millions de gens finale là où
j'habite bator du most a pour mot les
stars c'est quelqu'un qui a un grand
parcours qui a une aura excédera qui
représente quelque chose de gentil
l'arrêté six mois magali lynchage
normalement tu le sais mais les gens
d'arrêter je peux pas te laisser dire ce
sont des stars et alliances
jusqu'à parker isabelle adjani et c'est
ok je vais pas me dire que jazz c'est
impossible je vous le dis c'est
impossible ou alors ouais il faut
changer de voie il faut changer de voile
a de nouveau évoqué muller c'est une
certain en 3 4 millions follower et que
vous en allez non mais sans déconner
j'espère sur les réseaux sociaux
c'est comme cela s'est passé chez leur
mère à la baisse mais juste une chose à
voir on va bien voir le résultat de la
seconde émission mais ce que j'ai été
extrêmement surpris par le score de
cette première émission qui était à 5
millions de survivants sur laquelle vrai
single juste énormissime progresse mais
est-ce que vous avez vu comment s'est
foutu de la gueule des gens comme attisé
teasé tease et tisanes star vous avez vu
le regard du jury ou pas à la même heure
ont été surpris connaît là où je suis
désolé amant broderie une star c'est ce
que vous dites c'est simone signoret
c'est vanessa paradis
ce sont des gens mais non mais les stars
c'est ça une star alors effectivement on
parlait de vedettes celebrity mais
lorsqu'à qu'ils appellent ça veut d'être
singer ou célébrités
je pense qu'un problème aussi haut
niveau entre guillemets des stars parce
que vous allez peut-être revenir vers ce
que je dis ça serait bien qu'on soit
d'accord au moins une fois dans cette
émission monsieur pernikoff les stars en
fait je pense qu'aujourd'hui elles ont
peur entre guillemets du ridicule et ça
rejoint un peu votre spectacle je pense
qu'il faut avant de rire aussi des
autres faut savoir rire de soi-même il y
en a pas beaucoup qui veulent jouer le
jeu se rendre ridicule et l'a peut-être
qu'on aurait des grains de sable
alors oui c'est l'argent juste à
descharles en amérique
toutes les stars et des vrais je parle
de jim carrey je parle de deux de mel
gibson participe régulièrement à des
shows télé en france il ya une vraie
scission est une vraie barrière entre la
télévision et pour le coup le char
système regarder les jury de the voice
et mentalités il ya quand même des
bonbons des pistards ou des grandes
stars dans the voice non mais pourquoi
aussi vous avez la réponse ou pas wim
aux états unis viennent parce qu'il ya
de l'argent et qu'un nombre d où leur
donner un gros cash
et puis passer un griezmann le jury de
the voice mais entre 200 et 400 mille
euros par voire amusé à 100000 euros
voire un million d'euros par émission
c'est pas anodin